you
the born to be wild IMAX crew ventured
into Kenya to film the work of the David
Sheldrick Wildlife Trust an organization
that rescues and rehabilitates orphan
baby elephants the baby elephant is
incredibly fragile animal they're unable
to take care of themselves till they're
about eight years old so a two year old
elephant even though it weighs thousand
pounds is just a little toddler Daphne
Sheldrick is the first person to ever
successfully raised in infant elephant
in the early days we couldn't get the
milk formula right it was trial and
error over many years eventually Daphne
found a viable substitute for elephant
milk and she developed techniques to
keep the fragile orphans alive of the
200 rescue baby elephants to come
through the nursery over 130 have
survived you know they weren't live
unless they're happy so you know the
keepers have got to keep them as happy
as possible and that's not giving them
what they want little dust was
entertaining them playing with them
football just like human children the
youngest elephants required 24-hour
supervision
including all night in their stables
every morning they are escorted into
Nairobi National Park
so strong
after about two years the little orphan
elephants move out to this facility in
Tsavo National Park there they're
surrounded by wild elephants select rest
at boarding school these elephants take
over from the people you know they take
them to water holes they show them where
to eat and at the end of the day the
elephants come back because there's
still milk defendant it's a very gradual
process typically they'll go wild when
they're about eight and if that happens
gradually to the wild elephants will
take them out into the bush maybe first
sleepover one night since elephant's
can't see in the dark very well
sometimes they'd have been scared it
back so they be escorted back by one of
the bigger elephants and handed back to
the keepers and back into a stockade and
then maybe two weeks later he'll go out
again for a week and then we'll come
back for a couple days and then maybe
we'll just go
that's an amazing thing you see I think
elephants are the only animals that will
actually welcomed and embraced ranges
you could always be quite sure that when
you introduce a new elephant to the head
it will be treated as part of the others
you know you would see these elephants
you were 20 years old who are mentoring
to your old elephant the daphne raised
that 20 year old elephant 20 years ago
that's just amazing to be around in a
raising the elephants is irrelephant sir
this is their 50-year learning curve
you've got to carry on Daphne Sheldrick
hasn't shown that people can make a
tremendous difference for everyone who
worked on this crew it was humbling to
be around her because in the truest
sense she's sure of the earth